[Music]
welcome to the weekly climate show a
tornado week in british politics that'll
barely register as a puff of wind set
against the long-term impacts of climate
change but worry not i'm not going to
overdo the pinprick in the universe line
as what happens to uk leadership matters
to our lives the global push for
decarbonisation and let's face it it is
a cracking episode of the westminster
soap opera so i'll be sitting down with
hannah skye's climate expert to sink our
teeth into what by by boris means for
climate politics and it's also
wimbledon finals weekend this type of
racket is used by novak djokovic and
other top players but our interest lies
in what's inside it graphene a material
also taking center stage in climate tech
and later on i'll be serving up an ace
of a film ouch all about it
we'll also be asking why we aren't
making more use of the seas around
britain to create green energy and of
course we'll have our usual sprinkling
of audience questions and expert answers
but first to tragic events in the
italian alps it's often said that we
don't take the threat of climate change
seriously enough because it doesn't seem
fatal it doesn't appear on death
certificates but what happened in the
dolomites looks very much like cause and
effect
italy's northern alps are warming up
driving the retreat of its glaciers
they're estimated to have lost half
their ice since 1850 and it's been
happening a lot faster since the late
80s
it's not just the mountains in the po
valley rainfall is 60 percent below
average causing crops to fail along the
river a drought has been declared across
the whole region
the marmalade glacier is known as the
queen of the dolomites and it's from
there where siobhan robbins reports
in northern italy
this helicopter team is on a grim
mission
they're heading to the site of the fatal
glacier collapse
their job
to locate the dead
if we see
anything like the
parts of equipment or some clothes i
retrieve it
this is the moment a huge chunk of
glacier on marmalade mountain broke off
triggering a landslide as it hurtled
down the slope
when the glacier collapsed 260 000 cubic
meters of snow and rock and ice flew
down the mountain at more than 300
kilometers an hour there
as we fly closer you can clearly see the
hollowed-out area where the collapse
happened it's believed a warm winter and
a summer heat wave melted the ice making
it unstable italy's prime ministers
blamed climate change
in this part of the year is not normal
this high temperature and we see the
glacier melted probably
in the next decades the glacier
disappear
really disappear completely yes probably
yes
five areas of northern italy are in a
state of emergency due to drought water
levels have dropped eight meters in
parts of the longest river the po
here exposing boats sunk in world war ii
this kind of summers
are actually what we expect for climate
change so uh in the future in the
different scenarios and in particular in
the more extreme scenarios where there
is no mitigation in terms of emissions
of co2
we will we will expect exactly what we
will saying
even the world famous cheese
parmigiano-reggiano
is being affected
the extreme heat is hitting milk
supplies
luca says the drought has damaged the
crops needed to feed his cows
the high temperatures also stress the
herd reducing their fertility and the
amount of milk they produce
we must survive we already designed air
conditions stable to adapt our business
another solution has been calling for
authorities to create water containment
basins
people here now have no choice they have
to adapt
saving water
changing crops and braving the heat
as italy bakes
siobhan robbins sky news northern italy
now it's time to skip over to our data
dashboard and this week we have got 33
percent of our energy from renewable
sources this week last year it was just
22. now the energy sources behind that
are wind solar and hydro
not tidal because there is virtually
none why not why don't we harness the
power given to us by the moon as its
drag gravity drags water across the
oceans because unlike unpredictable
weather you could set your watch by the
tides for millennia well to talk about
this our science correspondent thomas
moore is with me because you've made a
film about this thomas what did you find
out yeah i've been to the only tidal
power station in europe it is in
brittany northern france it's a place
called laurence and we've got some
pictures that really show how it works
it is an enormous dam that stretches
across the estuary of the river and that
channels the sea the incoming tide
through 24 giant turbines and it
produces enough electricity for 220
000 people and the big question is well
if the french can do it then why can't
we we are an island nation and in fact
we have the second strongest tides in
the world got a map that really shows
their potential and you can see from the
warmer colours that's where the tides
are the strongest and the bristol
channel and up in north wales and the
north west
of england
people say that we could build seven
plants by 2030 producing enough
electricity for four million homes so
given all those advantages why haven't
we what are the headwinds it's money
every time it's money isn't it and it is
the upfront cost which is holding this
back because it costs billions of pounds
to build these enormous sea walls they
need to be extremely strong to survive
the power of the waves and that's where
the cost comes and it's not going to get
any payback until many years into the
future but the payback does come say the
advocates but they is of course a big
cost with nuclear too and many people
say well that's what you've really got
to compare it against these are big
concrete structures too
and hinckley point c 26 billion pounds
and it's taken what 10 12 years for that
to be built so i think this is a big
problem and certainly uh the advocates
of tidal power uh have say that this is
something that can be overcome
lagoons in liverpool bay they will last
120 years whereas nuclear will only last
60 years but the biggest challenge
you have that nuclear waste which we
have to manage for many centuries into
the future now if you build a lagoon out
there or a ballard here and after 120
years you decide you want to take it
down that can be taken down with no
serious
implications of dealing with the waste
now the other big thing about this kind
of tidal power that requires building
these big barrages is a big impact on
our natural environment and i believe
that's what's tripped up the uh bristol
the seven estuary barrage that was
proposed a few years back very much so
because that is a really important site
for birds to feed on on those mud flats
and if the tides aren't working properly
then they can't uh get their food source
and certainly it is something that even
the big advocates of tidal recognize
that you've got to look at the sighting
very carefully do an environmental
impact and at laurence they know that
that has
changed the salinity of the water but
also how much water comes in and that
has affected the ecosystem but it has
reached a new balance so the feeling is
that
as long as you look carefully things can
be overcome let's face it all uh sources
of energy do have uh some kind of impact
and carbon dioxide coming from gas and
coal and even something like solar if
you build it on agricultural land that
might affect food security and just a
quick thought you sold the kind of fact
that we have very good tidal resources
as a as an advantage but on the other
hand it makes it seem like this tidal
power might not be something that will
attract global investors because it's
kind of unique to britain or maybe a bit
of canada and that's true and if you're
looking at a new technology and
investing in jobs you'd want to export
that around the world that's how you get
your money back in some ways bit like
wind technology and how that's changed
things here
it's really a matter of the here and now
isn't it we are in an energy price spike
and we're also talking about energy
security and and this is why many people
say we should be taking a closer look at
tidal well it'll be very interesting to
see if we can turn the tides on tidal
thomas more thank you very much indeed
and you can see thomas's full report and
all our other climate content by
scanning the qr code on screen now
last week you might remember i went to
stockport to take a look at retrofitting
homes for energy efficiency which led
one viewer chris to write in to ask us
how as a pensioner on a limited income
he could future-proof his home to limit
heat loss and maximize that energy
efficiency well a puzzler for many this
chris so here are the basics some
changes are relatively cheap thick loft
insulation and draft exclusion on doors
and windows can make a big difference
for little outlay if you're on benefits
you might get help from your energy
company to install fuel saving measures
under what's known as the eco scheme
it's true new windows and solid wall
insulation do cost many thousands but
it's being increasingly recognized that
they do add the volume value of your
property so if you're a homeowner
investing now might pay off via lower
fuel bills in the future
coming up after the break we'll be
asking what boris johnson's downfall
means for climate change policy
[Music]
welcome back to the climate show with me
tom heap now boris johnson is going but
what impact will his departure and
replacement have on the government's
climate policy who better to meet for a
cup of tea to talk about this than our
climate change and energy correspondent
hannah thomas peter oh look there i am
plenty of over-excited political
correspondents this week but the quite a
lot for us climate nerds to get into as
well yeah huge what a week i mean boris
johnson remember he
set the stage on climate change he
really led the uk remember cop 26 and
all of that global statesmanship you
know that was a big deal for the way the
uk is seen by the rest of the world and
tackling climate change so he pushed the
profile of climate a lot but a few
questions over the detail and delivery
lots and lots of questions over there
climate change committee's saying that
as it stands the government's not going
to hit net zero with its plans on
climate change so that was a big blow
for the government anyway here's history
what next who next rather here's history
so i've been talking to a few people
involved in all of this watching very
closely the runners and the world is
emerging so let's take for example rishi
sunak you know that's that's a
chancellor who struggled a little bit to
come up with a way to pay for the cost
of net zero really reluctant to hike up
green taxes for example but who is
fairly central you know as a centrist
and he's going to pursue the net zero
agenda because he along with the likes
of sadie javid jeremy hunt he believes
it's the right thing to do economically
but knows it's the right thing to do
politically because voters really care
about climate change what evidence do we
have for that well polo after poll has
said that voters up and down the country
consistently put it in top three issues
but they are not the only candidates out
there no there are some that are
worrying the climate change caucus of
the conservative party like for example
liz truss foreign secretary very first
speech she ever gave in that seat she
didn't even mention climate change much
more focused on other issues and steve
baker who's a really worrying character
for those who are interested in the
climate change agenda he's very
skeptical yeah i remember his name over
the last few months he's actually been
heading up a bit of a campaign to
undermine the whole net zero target
steve baker is in charge of the net zero
scrutiny group and
he knows that net zero as a target is
enshrined in law but he's really pushing
back on the way we get there and he's
saying look the nanny state's going to
get into your life and tell you what car
to drive and how to deal with your home
and it's going to have an unacceptable
impact on the quality of the lives of
british citizens so he's playing it as a
kind of populist government get off our
back agenda is he exactly right and he's
a feared organizer he's the architect in
many ways of brexit
now i guess this might hinge in the end
on how this plays in relation to the
cost of living crisis and the money
behind all this yeah and that is the
tussle at the heart of the conservative
party right now is it does this
uh energy crisis security crisis and the
the cost of living crisis does this
provide all the evidence we need to
accelerate investment in renewables and
go guns blazing on the climate change
agenda or is it going to cause people to
turn away and get more interested like
steve baker is and things like fracking
and more extraction of fossil fuels
because of the dependability of these
things in his mind now you talk about
the cost of these things we had some big
news this week at least for folks like
us about the amount and cost of future
renewable generations huge relief for
the government list they oversaw an
auction gave out contracts to uh
renewable electricity generators to
generate a huge amount of clean power 11
gigawatts enough to power 12 million uk
homes and they're guaranteeing they're
going to sell electricity at low prices
because they know that it's economic to
do so and it you know it's a really good
win for the government and for the
renewable industry but it's also going
to protect consumers
and so in the end does this show that
almost the froth of politics is not
irrelevant but the engineering and the
economics are kind of moving in the
right direction that is it's all about
where the flow of capital is going where
industry is interested where they're
going to invest in infrastructure and
training
and all of that stuff and you know one
one person who shall remain remain
nameless who's very senior in in
policymaking and climate change said you
know actually at the end of the day the
flow of capital and the sheer momentum
is such that it's the renewable energy
in particular is likely to succeed in
spite of the government doesn't actually
matter what the government does at this
point because of the direction of travel
and that flow of capital
after infamous carbon dioxide the second
most important gas causing climate
change is methane it's what billows out
of the digestive system of cows and
powers your cooker or heating if you run
on natural gas
each molecule warms the climate 30 times
more than co2 so something to reduce
that would be very welcome
here on the outskirts of cambridge
they're working on a piece of tech that
turns something that we don't want
methane in the atmosphere into two
things that we do hydrogen a clean fuel
and also graphene a so-called miracle
material
it's all happening
in this unassuming shipping container
this is where the magic happens did you
get that door for me
pretty hefty
here we go
wow
so come on through
what are we looking at at this end
that's where the gas comes in into the
process okay so methane in this end and
then it goes through to here so we move
the methane through so as we walk
through we're following the path of the
methane and the microwaves then interact
with the methane and that's our our
magic our secret sauce is how that works
um but essentially when you when you
bombard the methane with the microwaves
it gives it energy and that makes the
methane break into its component atoms
the carbon and hydrogen which we're
interested in
whether flared off from oil terminals or
leaking from pipes methane warms the
atmosphere the molecule itself is ch4
simply carbon and hydrogen the lavidian
process splits that molecule to deliver
pure hydrogen a climate friendly fuel
and carbon as useful graphene
so what happens then to those two things
that the graphene and the hydrogen so we
collect the graphene here and the
hydrogen we collect uh and either
separate it or use it directly as a
hydrogen-rich gas blend
you can see it's really light and fluffy
because the powder is so fine it almost
looks like smoke
and this is a flask of the graphene
itself usable for so many things harder
wearing tyres stronger concrete and even
better performing batteries and how do
they ship it out in these rather
refreshingly low-tech buckets
[Music]
this gym floor under construction is
made with graphene enhanced concrete as
a result they used 30
less concrete so shrunk their carbon
footprint
both the process and the product are
climate change wins
so john what's in this rather sci-fi
queue
so this is a kilogram of graphene
material it's very light and that allows
you to add it to a range of different
products and it's formed from methane
gas
john hartley runs the project but your
process needs energy to drive those
microwaves does it still stack up for
the climate with that yeah it does
require electricity so the unit which
produced this for example makes about
200 grams per hour it uses about 10
kilowatt hours of power and you'll get
this in a five hour period
so though it's not a miracle low energy
hydrogen generator its attraction lies
in doing so many useful things in a
transportable metal box capture methane
create green fuel and make graphene
which is so vital for more
climate-friendly tech we're going to
need solar and battery and wind to keep
growing as well so it is a magic bullet
and we're optimistic about the impact
that it can have but we're going to need
a few
[Music]
as john says when it comes to these kind
of solutions it's always about more than
just one and for theirs to work the
electricity must come from renewable
sources for it to stack up in terms of
the climate now we still have a little
time to answer some more of your
questions and this one is something i've
heard a few times in the past so was
keen to hear from an expert
mike asked me on twitter if the planet
has been warming for decades
then why has antarctic sea ice been
trending up for decades so we asked ella
gilbert who studies this stuff and works
at the british antarctic survey for an
answer hi mike thanks for a great
question you're right that total
antarctic sea ice area was growing until
about 2015 although there were declines
seen in some regions the jury is still
out but scientists believe this is due
to changes in the atmosphere and oceans
human activity has changed wind patterns
around antarctica meaning winds blow sea
ice further away from the coast and sea
ice forms in the gap
at the same time melting antarctic ice
sheets encourages sea ice growth because
fresh melt water freezes at a warmer
temperature than salty sea water
however since 2015 sea ice extent has
plummeted and we saw record minima in
2017 and 2022
sadly this is probably more of what we
can expect as the planet heats up
and another one this from phil who sent
in his question via our app he asks
since the depths of the last little ice
age 330 years ago the earth has been
warming which part of this warming is
natural
well phil you're right to say it was a
bit colder in the 1700s that was known
as a mini ice age i don't have data
going back that far but what i do have
are numbers from the global warming
index to show you what's happened since
the industrial revolution when things
really started to warm up
this line shows you man-made warming and
this one is natural warming and cooling
so that's volcanoes for example and here
you can see them both together so that
you can see although natural factors do
account for some of the changes the
warming is driven
mainly by us
and if you want your questions answered
just go to skynews.com forward slash
climate or to any of our social media
accounts where you can add your
questions in the comments we've had
plenty of them and not enough time to
answer so we'll soon be putting more of
them to our correspondents and experts
online
and now some news showing how good
policy can right past environmental
wrongs
fin whales the second biggest species
have been seen in great numbers in their
ancestral feeding grounds for the first
time since the whaling ban of 1976.
this is great for wales but also experts
point out that it should help the whole
marine ecosystem by firing up what they
call the nutrient pump a koi way of
saying that whale poop is a favorite of
plankton
and on that savory note that's all for
today
see you next week for the weekly climate
show
[Music]